back to las vegas now okay get your best
vintage vegas outfit ready because this
weekend the junior league of las vegas
is hosting a special event in downtown
las vegas and it's all done through the
royal crawl app a fun digital bar crawl
experience joining us today to tell us
all about this weekend's festivities is
the president of the junior league of
las vegas kate newman alongside ivan
grant who is one of the flare bartenders
you will meet on the bar crawl thank you
guys so much for being here thank you
very much all right kate let's jump
right into it let's talk a little bit
about what the junior league is and why
events like this are so important for
your organization well thank you junior
league is an organization of women here
in las vegas we've been here for 75
years
and we are a training and development
organization for women and we train
women to be leaders in our community and
we do that by working together with
community partners junior league has
helped found things like the children's
discovery museum
the ronald mcdonald house and this year
we're focused really on helping kids in
our community overcome some of the
adverse impacts of the pandemic by doing
teacher grants and working on our
project very much like fashion runway
project runway and uh and also with the
shannon west homeless youth center wow
you guys really do some incredible
things in the community and i know a lot
of the women that are involved with
junior league some really amazing women
some of which even work here at channel
8. so we're really excited about this
event this weekend and
the way you do it is you download the
royal carl app through your smartphone
device and you can buy a ticket through
that and then proceeds go back towards
the junior league and ivan i'm going to
bring you in here because you are one of
the bartenders at circa right uh at the
end of the day it says on your shirt i
should know that
we're all under the same umbrella i'm
going to let you whip up your cocktail
here today you said you're making
something refreshing very refreshing i'm
making a nice simple drink we're going
to make a cherry vodka lemonade
something easy that you guys can come
down and definitely order on your bar
crawl with us all right i'll start
having you make the drink and the bar
crawl was really fun because you buy the
ticket and it includes five stops along
the way five different bars five
different drinks but these are just
regular bars you guys put on a show how
does it feel to have everyone come in
from the crawl and you guys really make
it fun you know that that's i think one
of the best parts of it is you know
people are already excited they're here
the on the bar crawl you collect uh
different cards and that's why it's five
stops it's like a hand of poker and uh
and i'm usually the last stop on the
trip
so at that point you know i'm i'm there
kind of rooting everyone on you know you
know as they're all sort of uh just
chiding each other saying you know i'm
gonna get the royal flush you know which
obviously everyone wants and and
eventually you know usually someone wins
with a four of a kind or something like
that but hey everyone's having fun by
that fifth stop
so i'm sure you have quite the
experience there absolutely so the goal
of all this is like to have a good time
usually you know i'm sitting here making
the drinks i'm not trying to throw the
glass bottles around in here but uh hey
you gave us a preview earlier definitely
you know you'll definitely get to see
a little bit of a fun little flipper
room
have a good time some laughs and you
know
win some prizes absolutely and gosh you
are a pro at that and kate this is just
one of the many of the fun things that
are going to be happening over the
weekend what else can people expect when
they come out to the crawl we have
prizes we have thousands of dollars
worth of prizes including tickets to
brooklyn bowl we have some of the bars
and restaurants downtown have gift cards
so when you get your full hand of cards
you might also get a prize oh well it's
so much fun and we'll have all the
information